[Musik]
philipp kurz erlebte die hölle auf erden
seine kindheit war von einsamkeit gewalt
und missbrauch geprägt viele jahrzehnte
hat er geschrieben
bis er seine stimme fand und das
schweigen brach
[Musik]
seine verbundenheit zur natur hat ihn
gerettet
natur hat mir einfach hin hat herr kraft
zum leben geschenkt
der bruch dass schwarzer kaputte teile
mehr familien das wort und auf der
anders sieht anja kruse fokussieren
früher landschaften sehr intensiv
ordnung wind naturfreund zu schaffen
sowie ein teil von natur losgelöst vom
schicksal lieber natur
[Musik]
in cholet philipp gurk mit trommelwirbel
zur lesung seines siebten romans
bündnerfleisch ein philips bücher
enthalten immer auch autobiografische
elemente unter den gästen ist auch seine
älteste schwester maria tipps schrieb
heimat wo mis härz motiv
emotionalisieren will dass ich
entscheiden wie man buch erlassen was
emotionen da gott zum ziel umziehen der
stammtisch sekunde das licht des ewigen
sommers fühlten uns eine mindestens dort
wo das verletzte einsame kindern im haus
das zugleich stark und schwach war und
auch immer nach der wärme rief war nun
licht dieses licht kam das kind in ihm
auf wie eine väterliche hand während es
so dass die vielen narben zart rosa
verblassten und gänzlich entstanden das
war sein innigster und einzige wunsch
seit er ein kleiner junge gewesen war
[Musik]
danke vielmals für winterschäden
entsprechend wie lange es braucht bis
durchbrach gefunden und sich wunderbar
dass du dir sprach sorgfalt und auch im
board mit menschen die ihr viel erfolg
fehlt philipp hat durch das schreiben
seine stimme gefunden
seine geschichten begeistern viele nur
über seine eigene geschichte schwieg
erlangen jetzt mit 48 jahren wagte sich
an die aufarbeitung seiner kindheit
in der gemeinde malagas wo philipp als
siebtes von acht kindern einer armen
bergbauernfamilie zur welt kam beginnt
seine spurensuche diesmal selber nicht
dass man den flieger nach spanien wo man
gespürt weil wir mit der vergangenheit
und der tour so lang her ist und
irgendwie spielt sieht wirklich carol es
ist übrigens kids sexy wie sein vater
ein hilfsarbeiter und alt wird war
schwerer alkoholiker trotzdem liebten in
die kinder sehr als cabrio zu der rabatt
der strehler der rechte hand das ist der
weizen in bartóks ida da ich ganz viele
reges interesse und das gehalt post dort
minimal minister steuern von 3,6
das ist doch so
als philipp vier jahre alt war verließ
die mutter ihren im alkoholrausch
gewalttätigen mann ohne ein abschied
wort und überließ ihre acht kinder dem
schicksal für alle ein schock
philipp oft in den akten über die
familie die der gemeindeschreiber von
malagas für philipp bereitwillig
herausgesucht hat endlich antworten auf
seine vielen offenen fragen zu finden
über die familie gurt haben die
damaligen behörden einen riesigen
aktenberg angelegt es ist schaltet so
darunter den mit ganzen ich weiß nicht
was das heißt kam es bald nach anschluss
zur schwersten auseinandersetzungen die
dazu führen dass die klägerin ihre
familien jahre 72 verließ die ehrlichen
auseinandersetzung gründen die bieten
acht unternehmen nicht zur hauptsache
auf dem steht den alkoholkonsum das
beklagt und teils auf den miserablen
wohnverhältnisse der familie philipp
entdeckt weitere abgründe dass das
originaldokument ist wo man auch
verstehe das sterilisieren besser zeit
organische gründe
kein nachwuchs quellensteuer ist also
somit auch aus hygienischen gründen
erscheint eine nachkommenschaft 36 plan
nicht wünschenswert wegen sogenannt
mangelhafter gene wurden in der schweiz
bis in die 80er jahre
zwangssterilisationen durchgeführt als
vaganten deklassiert galt philips ganze
familie als schwachsinnig und unwert das
ist ja genau das was sie denkt dann nur
noch grund dass ich nach der
abschlussprüfung ihrer mama so viele
schläge und streit hoffe ich werde ich
nicht mehr bekommen
ich mache euch darauf aufmerksam dass
ich die schaltung verlange der nicht
komme nicht mehr zurück
es ist natürlich brutal welt will auf
drei meter weiter sieht da war das
staunen ist mama knacken kann
easycash acht kinder ist kein wc muss
und dass die klage vor dem alkohol
mitarbeitern von iscsi und riesa als
könne sie ich glaube auf 3 und sieht
dass das schlimmste wohl eine spur
softer anders sieht das sind die
unzulänglichkeit examinierter wirklich
akn und zwischen triesen mehr als
familien kinder und das ist traurig wenn
das gericht nun jedoch hin dass stetig
denn acht rinder oder im
unterschiedlicher erweiterung für dort
die behörden verteilten die kinder in
verschiedene heime um die sippe zu
zerschlagen wie sie das brutale
auseinanderreißen der geschwister
nannten
bei philipp zuhause seine älteste
schwester maria konrad briefträgerin und
extremsportlerin kommt zu besuch
gemeinsam wollen sie ihr ehemaliges
elternhaus und ihre alb aufsuchen
beide waren seit dem auseinanderbrechen
der familie nie mehr dort seit über 40
jahren bist du mit der gummistiefel
damit die touristische nachfrage stärker
wir haben vor glück kannst du dir foto
noch auftrieb
ja aber die anderen itar-tass
lieblingsbild was mich bewegt ist erst
einmal dass wir jetzt einfach drauf sind
denn viele mieter beschützt oder
schlafen ruhig fuß sowie h kinder sind
und der vorteil für mich im bild
emotional 10 bild von max geborgen und
im nächsten moment in der heimat etwas
außerhalb von malagas in sax damals
vakanten vor ort genannt stand das
baufällige haus der familie
die zehnköpfige familie hauste in zwei
kleinen zimmerchen ohne wasser strom und
sanitäranlagen
im unteren stock lebten die großeltern
[Musik]
da hättest fordern atomkraft demo stelle
getan ihr foto wo dornhaner untermenü
hocken also wozu alter hut oder das haus
ist sich aber nur 25 und der das
original den steinboden
marie wird von erinnerungen überwältigt
als älteste versuchte sie damals
vergeblich das auseinanderbrechen der
familie zu verhindern
für philipp ist es das allererste mal
dass er seine ältere schwester weinen
sieht der zusammenbruch seiner geliebten
marie erschüttert ihn zutiefst
eigentlich wollten die geschwister
gemeinsam auf die alb straßberg die
sanft eingebettet in die bündner
bergwelt oberhalb von langwies liegt
doch mary muss heute den ort wo die
ganze familie als alphirten viele
unbeschwerte sommer in der natur
verbrachte ohne ihren kleinen bruder
besuchen sogar die einfache alphütte
steht noch hier entstand auch philips
lieblingsbild mit seiner schwester
der anblick der geliebten alb weckt
viele erinnerungen
ja es war schön
eine schöne jugend a und der spiele hält
sich da abzeichnet dass man macht gott
die kinder waren beim auseinanderbrechen
der familie zwischen 3 und 14 jahre alt
alle hatten mit einem schweren schicksal
zu kämpfen
ganz besonders philipp bietet am meisten
wirklich meister unter dem meer auch in
der heimat wo ihn einfach nicht los lipp
wurde als vierjähriger der familie
entrissen und im laufe der zeit in elf
verschiedenen heimen und pflegefamilien
platziert am längsten lebte er im
ehemaligen waisenhaus chor wo er mit
sechs jahren hin kam philipp hat
begonnen nach anderen heimkindern von
damals zu suchen und hat endlich sina
senioren gefunden mit der er
aufgewachsen ist
sina ist in begleitung ihres
lebenspartners an die gekommen 30 jahre
haben sie sich nicht mehr gesehen die
beiden ehemaligen weise hüsler wie sie
von allen beschimpft wurden betreten das
erste mal als erwachsene den ort an dem
sie der willkür gewalt und dem
missbrauch durch die damaligen
erzieherinnen und erzieher völlig
ausgeliefert waren
brutalität und essensentzug prägten den
alltag der verstoßenen kinder
essen als strafe so wurden die kinder
gezwungen das maskottchen des heims
ihren geliebten geißbock die cemag zu
essen aber dazwischen und dass der
hausmeister des heutigen therapie hauses
fürstenwald das heute nach modernsten
pädagogischen methoden geführt wird
öffnet den beiden das einst dunklen
kellergewölbe wo früher die schlachterei
war die brutalität kannte keine grenzen
das ist früher stöcklin stieg sie dann
hätten aber china und deutsch türke das
ist der camino guadagnino und wenn wir
schlecht denn oben aber durch das dunkle
ruder laufen auch hin zum der neckar in
das klima üblich dass er nie im meister
locker in den halbdunklen abend so ist
der sturm in den ring
fast täglich schlug der heimleiter die
wehrlosen kinder für philipp war die
natur rund um das ehemalige waisenhaus
sein einziger trost und der wichtigste
zufluchtsort auch für sina die mit zwei
jahren ins heim kam
sina war wie philipp kein waisenkind
sondern wurde mit ihren geschwistern der
alkoholkranken mutter weggenommen und
die hans so panik
für sina philipp und die anderen
heimkinder waren dies die glücklichsten
momente ihrer kindheit hier konnten sie
der fälle des weißen hauses entfliehen
und ihre einsamkeit und ihren schmerz
für kurze zeit vergessen
wir sind alle zimmer geöffnet und das
verwaltet worden oder her und das isch
kei also ich kenne oder wäre mit orks
sie weiß man jetzt keine sehr du hättest
hey ich weiß nicht wie du es empfohlen
heißt sondern die selber machen oder um
den schmerz zu betäuben stürzte sina in
die drogen ab erst vor wenigen jahren
schaffte sie dank ihrem lebenspartner
und dem glauben an gott den ausstieg wo
man keine dose spiele alles wunderbar
und das andere ich einfach halten sie
einfach geil einfach heute sich und ist
einfach irgendwie windschutzscheibe
gemacht um die uhr und das nimmt mir und
ich und ich kann endlich wieder mal ein
vertrauen wenn ihr kühlwasser 20 euro
gesucht jetzt ein neues tief ist am
labour denn ist dass das projekt nun
hart und wenig fühlt sind mit
traurigkeit abc vor dem was alles ist
erfreut der 200 sitze china und philipp
haben beide als kinder im waisenhaus
sexuellen missbrauch durch erzieherinnen
und erzieher erlebt der ire kinderseelen
schwer belastete
philipp möchte sich am ort des
geschehens seiner vergangenheit stellen
und nicht länger über die traumatischen
erlebnisse schweigen
die projektion der filmaufnahmen von
damals welche die täterin gemacht hatte
lassen in philipp die erinnerungen an
die schrecklichen vorfälle im waisenhaus
wieder wach werden
alles begann als die 25-jährige gruppen
leiterin philips einzige bezugsperson
eines morgens überraschend zum
sechsjährigen kinder gärtner ins bett
kam was als ameisen erkundigungs spiel
begann endete in einem massiven
sexuellen übergriff kann sie ja sowieso
was ich einfach viel druck sie und vor
allem die hand das bild immer zum krieg
durch die erzieherin wie abgöttisch
geliebt hat und durch verstehens etwas
seltsam klagte das seltsame regelt und
und dennis grote smi fast noch mehr
beschäftigt oder treffer dass sie immer
wieder versorgt mich sechs amerika falle
größer zu machen ihre wortschatz und
durchsichtigkeit mit einem katholiken
mit dem kann in die davor und sich
abgewendet
während einer von zb bei ihrer
körperlichen aufholjagd leid und ich
muss an wert der sechsjährige blieb
erstarrt und verwirrt zurück
sie hatten versucht über spieler
kassieren der missbrauch und düst filmt
als ob behrami und ich sehe jetzt wenn
ihr an ihrer familie auf und der blick
wieder zur wahl
der blick seinem fahrer robbin ivo
staune was ist passiert und das ist
eigentlich der morgen war alles kaputt
gegangen ist
für den kleinen philipp folgten jahre
schwerster sexueller missbrauch durch
diese und andere erzieherinnen oft
verbunden mit schmerzen und gewalt auch
männliche erzieher begingen übergriffe
und obwohl andere verdacht schöpften
griff nie jemand ein
auch nicht die heimleitung oder die
behörden hätten der storch matura durch
meine stimme verschwieg und stoff mis
härz und die zwei hälften dickel schon
immer zum turnier mit zimmer und so bin
ich zurück kleber und hand ganz ganz
viele ort möglich sei wie die meisten
kinder schrieb philipp auch als er sich
mit 13 jahren endlich wehren konnte erst
als erwachsener mann fand er die kraft
die haupttäterin zu konfrontieren ihren
angst was ist das für ein kühllaster
dass ramos seeger gott philips stoßen
wenn du falsch liegst du da ist doch
nicht einfach sagen immer genau wissen
indem er setze jetzt passiert glaubt
dass in luton sagte hallo thorsten
philipp boy mit der name funder
rückseite totenstille
weißt du warum das tier so habe ich
versucht creekside sie an all die orte
darauf gewartet und dann hat sie alles
zurück geht und dass ich und das wird
jedem missbrauchopfer seinen hof
millimeter alles so ist passiert wenn
ich erlebte philipp hatten und endlich
gewissheit dass alles so gewesen war und
begann das erlebte niederzuschreiben
nach dem telefonat schrieb in die
täterin briefe in denen sie sich selbst
bemitleidet sich aber auch offen als
kinderschänder in bezeichnete und sich
für ihre taten entschuldigt
es kam zu einer persönlichen begegnung
die in philipp großen ekel hervor rief
aber keinen hass philipp hat sie ihr
rund 15 prozent aller minderjährigen in
der schweiz erfahren sexuelle gewalt
doch viel zu oft werden ihre aussagen
angezweifelt um philipp bei seiner
spurensuche zu unterstützen haben sich
zu dieser pulli und wanda pro g2
ehemalige praktikant innen von
waisenhaus bereit erklärt über die
damaligen zustände zu sprechen von den
sexuellen übergriffen erfuhren die
beiden damals 18-jährigen
praktikantinnen aber erst viele jahre
später ich bin überglücklich mit 237
dann ist eine volks rede sie und glück
wir schon auf der hand des täters
einfach druck du bist der opa 10 11 xi
und die handy entweder als ganz ruhig du
hesch kein wort gesagt wer das hat viel
viel missbrauch passiert sind damit ja
auch stimmt also nicht schweizer also in
wählen gegangen oder nicht also wenn
möglich schlimme sache passiert ist
wieder der faser heute bei den einfachen
weg sieht wir einfach nimmer schweiz
sein können oder sich die gruppe leitet
martin und jedes jahr zum mara frau
beschrieb ihn intern ihr mit der sie
einst in ihrem exil von damals sind sie
als erwachsene frau sein wenn ich sie
die sitze sind das heißt für das bild
von anwendern sie sagen wir sagen der
schauer heimkind so unbestimmt
[Musik]
die beiden jungen praktikantinnen hatten
immer wieder versucht die kinder vor der
brutalität im waisenhaus zu schützen
dass die kinder auch sexueller gewalt
ausgeliefert waren war für beide ein
schock dass man nahm an dass die usa
dort ich kann dass unsere macht und
daytona der erzieherin und ein
heimleiter wo das deckt das ich für mich
ein untragbarer zustand werden abgehört
grafenaus dann nach übergriffen ist die
erste muster mega fahren sonst ästhetik
und was viel zeit für diese grenze
keiner der verantwortlichen von damals
war bereit öffentlich stellung zu nehmen
zudem sind alle akten aus dem waisenhaus
verschollen
der heutige cora bürgermeister
entschuldigte sich aber im namen der
stadt offiziell bei philipp für die
versäumnisse seiner vorgänger
philip hatte sich in verschiedener
therapien doch über den missbrauch
schwieg er lang
erst mit hilfe des psychiaters und
psychotraumatologie hans jörg hahn
begannen die tiefen wunden langsam zu
heilen der therapeut kennt die
schwerwiegenden folgen die missbrauch
auch durch die nächsten
familienmitglieder auslöst schuldgefühle
und selbst entwertung zerstören das
urvertrauen der oft jahrelang
missbrauchten kinder es projekte immer
wieder bestätigung ich bin schuld was
ich konsequenz fortan konsequenz ist
bemüht war
warum macht das immer mit mir hat ihn ja
irgendwie darf man das an schienen mit
mir und wenn es ist eine enorme
wiederholten gründer seinerzeit straße
in über 727 schlacht hans japan hat
philipp dabei unterstützt wie der
selbstvertrauen und ein stabiles
fundament aufbauen zu können
langsam seinen harten schutzpanzer
abzulegen und erstmals gefühle
zuzulassen dem niedergang habe ihn
jemand merkt dass das kind für dortmund
lebendig frisch mir wohnt und brüllt und
schreibt und nicht dass du in das
vielleicht wähle die krise liegt aber
das interessiert mich das veto mahnte
das wird abgeholt weil das wird heil
werden
das schreit immer noch fast an die dort
merkt dass man immer noch schreibt und
dem kind da half april entschieden
dein vater kind will jetzt super g und
ich will es mir selber wieder die gegner
ich kann mir noch so gut erinnern die er
stück für rosen empfangen und jens nicht
können
ich habe mich so geschämt denke ich kann
ihnen für die betroffenen ist es wichtig
sich von selbstverachtung schuldgefühlen
und aus der opferrolle zu befreien und
das schweigen zu brechen
hans japan möchte dass das wegschauen
endlich ein ende hat und
missbrauchsopfer unterstützung erfahren
deshalb hat er eine ausstellung mit
tableaus über die schrecken des
missbrauchs organisiert und zugang über
die emotionen über drohen macht über die
armee und die alle jene produzieren
auch das widersprüchlichen m3 oft
reichte sich david stuhl leber wenn du
missbrauch erlebt der stadt und auch
daran dass sie selbst es überall mit um
das verzerrt es verzeiht alle fahren ins
unklaren griechisches farbigen glich
aber nur gern nummer zu befinden was mir
dem bild sehr sehr fasziniert das ist
eine million die präsentation echt
fahrer bevor der kindheit an der 17
jahren großer strand mit vielen muscheln
wohl nur viele erlebnissen und glich
merke das ganze terminen strudel rund um
das schloss seinem ganzer immer kreis
und trotzdem versuchten den fahrer welt
irgendwie aufrecht zu erhalten
das ist eigentlich ein wiederum eine
frist gleichzeitig in die also du es ist
eine szene die der therapeut hat auch
eine spritze mit flüssigkeit
bereitgelegt mit der die
ausstellungsbesucher ihren gefühlen
ausdruck verleihen können
das schon wie einfach wohl hier
missbrauch erlebt hatte sosa bezeichnet
setzt auch sehr dankbar zehnjährige
sperre wort von den erzieherinnen im
bett
und das ist schmerzlich konsistent
überhaupt nicht kennt und zu anderen ist
das sind trainer das für den menschen da
liegt wo das us halted womit brühler
kann
in dem moment wo dieses schweigen
möchten hansjörg anne und philipp
brechen und allen betroffenen mut machen
sich hilfe zu holen
dass philipp das vertrauen zu einem
therapeuten fand war nicht
selbstverständlich denn seine erste
erfahrung mit einer psychiatrischen
einrichtung war dramatisch als philipp
15 jahre alt war begann er zu
rebellieren und riss immer wieder vom
heim aus eines tages als die polizei
philipp erneut aufgriff brachten sie ihn
ohne vorwarnung zur zwangs psychiatrie
sierung in die klinik werberings
erachtet und alex ist jetzt den sigma
als einziger jugendlicher unter schwer
psychisch kranken erwachsenen wurde
philipp im einstigen wachsam und der 24
stündiger beobachtung mehrere wochen
eingeschlossen
eine beängstigende erfahrung für den
rastlosen teenager als patient oder
waren sie viel ein psycho srk der demenz
schlauer
wenn ikea ist sind verwirrt sie ich bin
natürlich die jungs schick sie mit 15 da
die behörden nicht wussten wohin mit
philipp hielten sie ihn dort fest obwohl
es keinen grund dafür gab der aufenthalt
in der psychiatrie setzte philipp zu ich
bin einfach ja nur ab misst delikte sie
haben im box ort entwickler von ihrer
familie gesagt mir einfach aus jedem
heimat bei mami hat nicht aber in der
kölner denn wenig fordernd und schrubber
behörde schubert immer bitte treten und
das verunsichert
als philipp erneut flow wurde er in die
geschlossene abteilung des jugendheims
platanenhof gebracht um den entwurzelten
jugendlichen ruhig zu stellen für
philipp war die einzelhaft ein alptraum
doch es passierte auch etwas völlig
unerwartetes und ich bin für wacker mit
unsäglichen unglaublicher und ruhr angst
verlorenheit als ist sie wenn ich
irgendwo in der mitte vom weltall orange
weber völlig ausgeliefert und hat das
ist stellt sich sagt und denn in die
größte hoffnungslosigkeit in der schweiz
sind immer geschrieben gern schrieben
gläsern und so viele hundert die bürger
sind sind worte mehr das gewicht ich
sitze hier alleine mit meinen mit meinem
monster im dunkeln oder ohne macht eine
zeit in ungebrochener kraft waren sind
mein blut aus neuen wunden die alten
narben sind dick und stark geworden so
stark dass nun endlich flügel große
starke flügel daraus wachsen die mich
eines tages hinaus in den gegenwind über
die drei weisen wirken hinweg hoch ins
blau tragen werden
unter mir dann der silbernen und
leistende fluss inmitten grüner wiesen
und wenn dann in den dunklen nächten die
monster wieder an meiner türe scharen so
wird die endlich gefundene liebe mein
herz umhüllen und es ruhig und kräftig
schlagen lassen
philipp fand seine sprache die letzte
heim station war für ihn das heutige
schul und berufsausbildung heim albis
brawn wo er nach unzähligen
fluchtversuchen seinen schulabschluss
machte das heutige leitungsteam
begleitet philipp auf seinem schwierigen
rundgang und die richtigen moment denn
ich weiß dass hrubesch gewalt unter den
jugendlichen aber auch durch die
erzieher prägten den damaligen heimat
tag philipp erinnert sich an seine
früheren kameraden von denen viele durch
drogen oder selbstmord jung gestorben
sind krasse ja ich verrückt es
wahnsinnig 23 ist ja über das ist
schmidt gab es noch dort minute häberli
entweder er stress also mit böse zeit
aber die drevo in der weißwurst
originale mini linken und freddy drohte
markt und die miteinander jeder der
gemeinde war es so einige schnelle
treffer bedeutete so einheitlich kaputt
ja von den erwachsenen sind ja alles von
der heimleitung sie also heimleiter den
fc
das ist ein taxi nach
heute wird im albis brunnen jugendlichen
in entwicklungs krisen auf augenhöhe
begegnet eine schul oder
berufsausbildung soll ihnen eine
eigenständige zukunft ermöglichen möchte
noch einen letzten blick in seine heimat
werfen
philipp schloss die schule mit bestnoten
ab
nach langem suchen hat philipp einen
seiner damaligen freunde vom albis brody
helfenstein gefunden
in walenstadt besuchen sie gemeinsam das
grab ihres besten freundes michael
matthies der in die drogen abstürzte und
bereits mit 25 jahren starb
[Applaus]
[Musik]
friedrich ist direkt an trümmern
also sind alles kind sie was sie nicht
als die miete immer wieder ein studium
aus mir sie sind ja wir schließlich
quasi vorschule schule die hürde ist so
irgendwo in den bergen druckservern
tournee noch so viele junge menschen
stressigen zehn cent menschens 30 in der
foto udo rufe sind alle tot
auf dem bild und keine rasche sind keine
doch keinen über 25 geworden
philipp hat 30 ballone für eine
gedenkzeremonie für die viel zu früh
verstorbenen heimkinder organisiert dass
das wars jetzt haarscharf hätte dass
dort zum nächsten
[Musik]
alle blieben zehn kitas dort auch wenn
der familie
die dienste
rudi hat wie philipp viel gewalt und
schwere misshandlungen im schulheim
erlebt 33 jahre hat der gelernte
papiermacher und vater darüber
geschwiegen bis in philipp vor wenigen
wochen kontaktiert so unglaublich
durchgeschüttelt nutzen haben und
telefon mit sehr großer aufwand viel
miteinander und auch emotional für mich
ich das eine notlösung vor mir
eigentlich wirklich verstört was was
auch ich einfach schleusen auf und denn
ich hoffe und ich das mehr oder weniger
für mich sieht das mit den an gemacht
aber schon gegen mittag an das gestochen
und dass das bald oder das spox dass sie
die zisch ihren bis bis auf kuba gemerkt
der druck oder viele gemeinsame
erinnerungen verbinden die beiden
freunde
für ruhe die war die konfrontation mit
der vergangenheit ein schock aber auch
eine große erlöser
[Musik]
ja oder chef dick
ich mache zurück immerhin ccs thomas
braun ich denke es ist gut dass wir mal
als erwachsene
die harten jungs von damals können heute
ihre gefühle endlich zu lassen und so
die schwierige heim zeit besser
bewältigen
philipp erfährt von vielen seiten
solidarität
um den missbrauchs opfern eine stimme zu
geben hat sich die bündner songpoetin
baby fahrplan bereit erklärt ein lied zu
komponieren fantastische art zum
siegener musik machen ihn einfach druck
typisch fantastische künstler
ich war bei vielen leuten einen zugang
nur mehr über musik bilden geschichte
ist eine qual aber auch nicht sie sich
denn der weg nach usa was das kino so
noch ins leere baby studiert im studio
mit dem jugendensemble der singschule
chor unter der leitung von lee ann foley
das bewegende lied ein und betroffenen
mut zu machen
[Musik]
das hier zeit sagt ja ich bin da ich bin
immer da
dann lächeln deine sehnsucht dass ich
mir etwa sie nicht als ich zu denen
sondern das ist schwer jeder hat
irgendwo sich ihnen die hoffnung steht
jedem die kraft und meine hoffnung oder
als es sich wenn das passieren darf dass
menschen berührt oder menschen verbinden
das geschenk
du kannst schleier dann schweigen
[Musik]
es bleibt für immer das ist
immer wieder will sich philipp bewusst
seinen engsten stelle zum beispiel beim
klettern mit seinem freund christian
doch kleine zwischenfälle können ihn aus
der fassung bringen
wie hast du das im fall wird die erbin
zeit klemmt noch einmal ufer philipp hat
ein fleischberg freund krieg versucht zu
helfen wenn die verstecke nicht aber
kann mini will lieber selber bestimmen
ja aber wenn die biene maja ist mit zehn
minuten eimer scheiße und hanni kölner
u-bahn können aber und das ist das anime
vergessen das schwimmen als kindisch
philipp hat gelernt mit rückschlägen zu
leben aufgeben kommt für ihn nicht in
frage
beruflich hat philipp trotz
abgebrochener malerlehre eine steile
karriere gemacht und ist bis zum chef
informatiker in einem weltweit tätigen
konzern aufgestiegen aber prestige und
geld brachten ihm nicht die erfüllung
die er suchte
das wichtigste sind für ihn seine fünf
kinder von denen zwei söhne und eine
tochter bereits erwachsen sind zwei
kleine kinder im alter von fünf und
sieben hatte nun mit seiner zweiten frau
mit 19 jahren ist philipp bereits das
erste mal vater geworden
heute hat er mit all seinen kindern
regelmäßig kontakt philip besucht seinen
sohn patrick der ganz in der nähe von
corinne kieswerk als bauleiter arbeitet
der winzerfamilie anteil wie vor der
familie da schaut so stark sie aber zu
ziehen
man hätte ich sag dir ja kein kind haben
will die werden irgendwie gestört und
und wenn ich ein hund wird nicht wieder
züchtern
das ist der tenor sie mit 17 18 das
registriert und wo der minister kann
natürlich im hinterkopf du bist kein
wertvoller papa du wirst nie ein
wertvoller partner philips zweitältester
sohn patrick ist 25 jahre alt und
philipp bringt ihm regelmäßig sein
lieblingsgetränk auf die baustelle wie
war philipp als vater
dann hast du schwanken meinte ich
wahrscheinlich dass sie auf der ein herz
nach sieben konsequent wenn die kinder
jugendliche und ein glückliches kind zum
großen clans wie man das problem lösen
würde
ich habe das nur beruhigend zu wissen
wer macht sich schon gedanken aber dass
keiner rechtfertigung für die
misshandlung und funktionären als papa
wo ihm eine schlechte note geben
der cds pp gebe mir das schlechte und
der wirklich zeigt dass ich auch nur
reaktiv
philipp ist glücklich dass die drei
kinder aus erster ehe
trotz einer belastenden vergangenheit zu
selbstbewussten jungen menschen daran
gewachsen sind
seine erste ehe zerbrach nach 17 jahren
und philipp gibt sich eine große schuld
durch die aufarbeitung seiner
lebensgeschichte in seiner autobiografie
gelingt es philipp aber immer besser
alte muster zu durchbrechen
so auch in der liebe mit neffe berühre
gar nicht viel schöner von sexualität
als solches ist ein mehrfacher nackt sie
aber ab sparte vom in ihrer seele von
minen verminderter wäre mir das ist
alles nicht und ja und es hätten auch
braucht damit die körperliche vorgänge
oder gas muss überhaupt haben können
empfinden und irgendwie zu haben so ganz
technisiert okay ich sie aber was es
bedeutet gern seine finger berührt
anblick wärme das eu land braucht zum zu
mir lieber mit seiner zweiten frau
judith hat philipp eine neue liebe
gefunden und für die zwei kleinen
gemeinsamen söhne nimmt sich philipp
viel mehr zeit als früher als seine
berufliche karriere im vordergrund statt
sein sohn levi ist ein begeisterter
fußballspieler die großen alle einig
sind wirklich wunderbar crotta
einstellen job dort auch emotional sind
es ist super das ist super und der
klinik mit pani dawson's creek zum
fehler wohl wieder näher stand als krieg
machten ihm erstmal nicht so viel tk bin
sehr egoistisch auf mich selber bezogen
sie aber gefordert doch ein ist
versuchen besser zu machen
das größte
aber
ja
[Musik]
vor 20 jahren starb philipps vater an
krebs
kurz vor seinem tod übergab er philipp
das kreuz das er seither immer um den
hals trägt
wenn philipp ans grab seines vaters
konrad geht hört er immer sein damaliges
lieblingslied ihm möchte er das
allererste exemplar seiner autobiografie
schattenkind widmen
die auch eine aufarbeitung der ganzen
familien geschichte ist
[Musik]
alles unrecht was man einer verwandten
das habe ich schon schreiben das gar
nicht um rache oder genugtuung aber es
geht wieder stimme täuscht sagt standard
und tradition selbst durch surheim es
ist alles eine firma quadratkilometer
mit dem buch einem partner das gefühl
hatte ich einen abschnitt als der
schnitt um süßes
seine mutter hat philipp erst viele
jahre später wieder gesehen und erst vor
wenigen wochen kam es zur aussöhnung
zwischen ihr und ihren kindern die
geschwister von philips sind an der
buchvernissage am abend auch dabei dass
hierfür sind - sondern sie jetzt alle
schalter kind schaut täglich sehen der
donner ganze hofer ich freue mich darauf
der heutige abend will der heutigen zeit
vergeblich ist wichtigster moment können
zum schlimmste hinter oslo es ist
wichtig ganz wichtig dass man sein kind
auf der welt verstehen denn ausgehend
von konrad gurt und maria medingen acht
kinder hervor
wäre es nach den behörden von damals
gegangen gebe es überhaupt keine familie
gourmet die aufgrund der erbanlagen
meiner eltern spricht des stammbaumes
wollten sie gar keine gen träger von uns
in dieser welt haben
[Musik]
wir hatten verloren erst wollten sie
nicht dass papa kinder in die welt setzt
und nun wollten sie uns aufteilen und
schwächen in ihren augen waren wir eine
debile ver ganzen sippe für unsere
familie war dies ein rabenschwarzer tag
dem noch viele weitere folgen würden
[Musik]
essen nichts bleibt für immer das ist
ein paar
[Musik]
das ist ein
das wird jedem selber missbrauch und
gewalt erlebt hat oder erlebt hast wenn
du wirst gift suchen und hoffe das
trenngitter stirbt das er der täter kann
die mit heiler du bist es der wert dass
jeder versucht das skore zu machen
versuchen dem mond stoff oder zwei mal
oder wenn es jetzt noch ins gesicht
lorger hilft der zoll
du bist nicht allein und das ist mir
gelungen
ich bin da
philipp weiss dass er die vergangenheit
nicht ungeschehen machen kann
aber er hat gelernt mit ihr zu leben
jeden tag schönes zu entdecken und mit
mut und zuversicht in die zukunft zu
schauen
[Musik]
für den h